es ist das größte rätsel der physik und
könnte jetzt die dunkle materie gefunden
werden
etwa 80 prozent der gesamten materie im
universum sind der dunkle materie
zuzurechnen und trotz intensiver suche
konnten fachleute sie bis heute nicht
dingfest machen gibt es sie also
wirklich ein forschungsteam aus mainz
nutzt jetzt cäsium dampf um extrem
leicht tempo so nitsche teilchen
aufzuspüren diese gelten als
vielversprechende kandidaten stehen wir
also kurz vor dem lang ersehnten
durchbruch klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocken und dann verpasst er nicht
los geht's herzlich willkommen dimitri
butter ist physiker an der universität
mainz und vergleicht die suche nach der
dunkle materie gerne mit einem großen
elefanten der mitten im raum steht und
trotzdem nicht von uns gesehen wird
dieses bild macht die wohl größte
herausforderung der modernen
grundlagenphysik deutlich physik teams
weltweit wissen ganz genau dass es die
mysteriöse dunkle materie geben muss
denn sterne bewegen sich beispielsweise
viel schneller als sie es tun würden
wenn es nur normale materie geben würde
doch bisher ist man noch unsicher wie
dunkle materie endlich aufgespürt werden
könnte eine große frage dabei ist woraus
sie genau besteht dafür kommen
verschiedene teilchen infrage unter
anderem extrem leichte bosnische
teilchen auf genau die hat sich ein
forschungsteam aus mainz konzentriert
und hat jetzt ein neues verfahren
entwickelt um potenziellen dunkle
materie teilchen auf die schliche zu
kommen ein dampf aus caesium atom wird
mit hilfe der atom spektroskopie genauer
analysiert konkret werden die atom und
dazu mit laserlicht angeregt dafür ist
eine ganz bestimmte wellenlängen
notwendig sobald der csu um dampf dann
an ein feld aus dunkle materie teilchen
ankommen sollte sich die wellenlänge
minimal verändern so zumindest die idee
des mainzer forschungsteams die extrem
leichten bosnischen teilchen sehen die
fachleute als vielversprechende
kandidaten dazu dimitri bubka der an den
experimenten beteiligt ist diese können
wir auch als klassisches feld ansehen
das mit einer bestimmten frequenz
oszilliert wie groß diese und demzufolge
die
der teilchen ist wissen wir aber nicht
unsere grundannahme ist dass dieses
dunkle materie feld an die sichtbare
materie an koppelt und dabei bestimmte
eigentlich konstante eigenschaften der
atome sehr so viel verändert tatsächlich
beschreibt dieses vorgehen der fachleute
aus mainz die suche nach dunkler materie
sehr gut es werden hypothesen
aufgestellt und das spezielle
theoretische modell wird dann in
experimenten geprüft das mainzer
forschungsteam arbeitet mit dem
sogenannten redaktion modell das von
israelischen fachleuten entwickelt wurde
hierbei wird davon ausgegangen dass
große massen wie etwa die erde ein
bereich in ihrer nähe zur folge haben in
dem die dichte von dunkler materie groß
ist hier sollen deren kopplungs effekte
leichter aufzuspüren und zu beobachten
sein das mainzer forschungsteam wird das
bisherige vorgehen als einen wichtigen
schritt in die richtige richtung denn es
konnten frequenzbereichen für die suche
nach dunkler materie zugänglich gemacht
werden die bisher unerforscht waren
dimitri butt gar fasst das so zusammen
in dem frequenzbereich den wir in
unserer aktuellen arbeit durchsucht
haben hat sich die dunkle materie bisher
nicht zu erkennen gegeben aber immerhin
wissen wir nun nachdem wir diesen
bereich durchkämmt haben dass wir dort
nicht weiter suchen müssen
der physiker selbst vergleicht die suche
nach dunkler materie mit der suche nach
einem tiger in der wüste man weiß dass
er dort ist aber man weiß nicht in
welchem bereich der wüste sich das tier
genau aufhält durch das experiment in
mainz wurde das objekt der begierde zwar
im bislang ab gesuchten bereich noch
nicht aufgespürt doch die fachleute
wissen nun dass sie in diesen speziellen
bereichen nicht mehr weiter suchen
müssen dazu butt gar so grenzen will den
teil der wüste in dem der tiger sein
kann immer weiter ein und irgendwann
werden wir ihnen auf diese weise finden
naja optimistische annahme dunkle
energie anklicken anschauen und dr
wurzel abonnieren mega cooler kanal bis
dann bleibt dran